muy buenas noches para ustedes pues aquí
ya es más de la medianoche y como
ustedes pueden ver todavía hay personas
que vienen hasta aquí hasta frente del
estadio san paolo para pues tener un
momento de recogimiento en frente de
estos cientos de mensajes de bufandas de
camisetas de flores que la gente ha
venido a depositar aquí justamente en
las las rejas de entrada de la curva
de este estadio san paolo como usted lo
decía así ya casi son para gente tres
días a que maradona pues se dejó de
existir pero para los napolitanos él
sigue vivo la gente ha continuado a
venir niños hemos visto gente con los
papás los hijos incluso vimos a la
policía venir en un momento y bajarse de
la patrulla y tomar algunas fotos de
estos metros y metros y metros y metros
de de homenaje y de souvenir que le han
hecho
al astro argentino así que pues los
homenajes continúan aquí incluso hasta
en las pancartas de publicidad ya hay
varias campañas de publicidad que en
realidad de varias marcas que han
aprovechado también para darle un último
adiós a diego armando maradona natale
usted lo decía los napolitanos piensan
que para los napolitanos maradona sigue
vivo podríamos decir que el nápoles
siente que maradona fue un napolitano
más a raíz de su paso por su equipo de
fútbol
efectivamente puede decirse porque hemos
hablado con varios napolitanos desde que
llegamos a esta ciudad y en todos está
esa boca en la boca de todos está el
decir que se trata de más de un campeón
de un hombre y aman al hombre a pesar de
las dificultades que haya tenido en la
vida privada a todos nos decían a
nosotros no nos importa a nosotros nos
importa ese hombre que era caluroso que
cada persona que ha podido o que cruzó
en su camino con el de maradona aquí en
las calles por ejemplo en el barrio
español es donde están esos murales
donde está la cara gigantesca de
maradona pintada sobre los edificios
pues la gente en realidad lo ama como
alguien como si fuera de aquí porque en
realidad fue alguien que en esa época de
los 80s un momento que estaba muy
difícil económicamente socialmente para
para nápoles y para esta región pues se
llegó él a entregar el felicidad
entregar las risas y hacer a alguien más
del pueblo entonces nos decían sí que
era alguien básicamente como ellos y
para ellos lo que admiran pues ese a
este hombre a pesar de su rebeldía y a
pesar de los problemas que haya tenido
decía nosotros no nos importa a nosotros
nos importa si el gran jugador que es
que no hay nadie como él nos decía hace
un momento un taxista así que como
ustedes lo pueden ver pues esta es como
la segunda casa de maradona